[Music]
I've been driving to Toronto during
Thanksgiving for probably 20 years now
eventually when I get to a certain age I
may not be able to drive that
long-distance anymore am i young I want
a cell bearing car to drive me there on
it sir I was always fascinated by car
industry and then this is the next big
thing in the industry like having
autonomous cars it also like Volvo gives
accidents we have and traffic I really
don't like traffic driving so that will
be an awesome future I've been working
on as a sub engineering for many many
years and I kind of get bored so I need
to new motivation new new inspirations I
noticed a lot of automation is a lot of
AI but mostly are on a research stage
and recently hallows research Brazil are
come into a resort that can be applied
to the production immediately that's
just got into me so that's that's the
program I want to get into the field of
self-driving car connects mobility with
the built environment and enables us
completely
modes of transportation and by that use
of spaces for example during the ride as
I'm working in the real estate business
it's interesting to access those kind of
new spaces initial hours reading stories
and the news is about Tom is driving in
self-driving cars but I didn't expect it
to develop so fast after one day I read
news about our company collaborating
with way more to upgrade our car with
the self-driving technologies then I
told myself that distance theorists and
I need to know more about it I spent
almost two and a half months on the
first prochik of the third term of the
path planning project that was quite
challenging to some some patients from
my family and myself but at the end it
was really worth doing that some of the
times that I was working on this I only
had maybe three or four hours to sleep
each night but I think the outcome
speaks for itself it's very rewarding if
I put into this new degree is more and
if I put into my master degree in the
college when I first started I was
interning up in Portland OR Tangela
trucks and so I was working during the
day and I was doing the program at night
so it was quite hard to balance
everything that my wife was super
supportive let me be in front of my
computer for like three hours at night
it's just coding and letting the models
or NIMS training you can't just drop
everything in your life to do a nano
degree but then you can't drop the nano
degree either because it's something
that you know yeah there's a time
limiter
you can't put it to the side burner and
think that everything will be fine I
guess that doesn't work out that way so
you have to put yourself that's the only
way to say this all depends on a student
how much time they want to put into or
how much they can get from the program
if you just want to pass the test and
that's all you do that's fine too but
for me this is very good educational
system it won't be easy
but still as long as you are doing the
thing that you are interested in I
wouldn't say it will be a burden it's
still one of a kind there is nothing
else like it where else can you download
a code that you and your teammates built
together into a real salt driving car
that has a real system that you likely
making move around a test track that you
program the experience is awesome
there's no other way of putting
[Music]
Oh